but in a much ballyhooed New York Times
up that former Facebook co-founder Chris
Hughes called for the breakup of the
company he built with his buddy Mark
Zuckerberg during their harvard days now
his piece got him booked far and wide
across the media landscape this is a
monopoly a market is frozen there is no
competition and there's no
accountability
the time is up there have been too many
scandals there have been too many
problems it's up to government to come
in break up the company and set this
baseline of standards okay who is Chris
Hughes he was the Harvard classmate of
Zuckerberg where of course they founded
the social media giant Facebook now he
left the company over a decade ago with
a small yeah
very lucrative stake valued at roughly
850 million dollars that's about 1% of
the company
well after he cashed out though Hughes's
vault he was volunteered for Barack
Obama's 2008 presidential campaign and
then he used his newfound wealth to buy
the notorious liberal New Republic
magazine inserting himself as editor
tried to rehab that revive that well
didn't work ended up selling that off a
couple years later recent years he's
become a proponent of universal basic
income
well it's only when you know all of
those liberal bona fide ease that Hughes
has that you start to understand the
real thinking behind his call to break
up the social media giant his main gripe
is this quote I'm disappointed in myself
an early Facebook team for not thinking
more about how the news feed algorithm
could change our culture influence
elections and as my favorite empower
nationalist leaders and Trump well there
it is my guess is that a few thought
Facebook was amplifying the right voices
meaning the left voices then there
wouldn't be the need for this correction
I like there plenty of issues with
Facebook privacy monopoly power etc all
of which we've documented on this show
but to suggest that the movements around
the globe in Europe and beyond things
like brexit the rise of trumps economic
policies
they're only popular because of Facebook
it's just ludicrous completely missing
the point and at bottom I think this is
typical leftist snobbery we don't like
your ideas so they can't be organic it's
kind of like the way they treated the
Tea Party back in 2010 they called it
all astroturf it didn't matter well the
same thing happened with Trump's
election disillusioned elites were so
shocked that they had to create another
reason for their loss and in the end
well the break of a Facebook and I might
even be a good idea but the reasons
they're putting forth aren't that
convincing so with the emergent of
emergence of these social media
companies as the main vehicle for
disseminating free thought to break them
up on these grounds could actually have
a chilling effect on speech that some of
the former leaders or even current
leaders of Facebook don't like